the state of Nevada is experiencing an
internet outage now this is impacting
most State websites and services
including the DMV as repairs are
underway many nevadans are frustrated
about the pause and service and the lack
of notification
what's the whole purpose of your visit
here to transfer plates from our old car
to the new one and I was going to use
the kiosk Hopewell says she tries to
avoid the DMV by doing all her tasks
online but after an outage at the DMV
her simple task is about to become a big
problem that's a concern because yeah in
five days I will be able to drive all
DMV locations were closed on Friday with
only this notice on their door the
online failure happened around 5 30
Thursday afternoon according to the
governor's office announcing that most
State websites and services were facing
an internet outage due to a physical
failure with a fiber connection due to a
fire that left many frustrated I wear
graveyard shifts so yesterday was my day
off but so I had to wake up early today
kind of mess with my schedule so tonight
when I go in it's going to mess with
that and so it's like I have to
rearrange my schedule it's pretty
frustrating I mean it's more that you
don't get like a notification like Hey
we're closed so you drive all the way
over here wake up early waste your time
not All State agencies were impacted
some offices had working phones emails
and internet views were still not
working on Friday in southern Nevada and
Elko I can't do anything and I have like
a five-day countdown for insurance to
get that changed over or be an uninsured
driver
well the governor's office reports that
the repairs are underway but they gave
no timeline now the DMV official that I
spoke to this morning said all
appointments will be rescheduled once
the system is back online